when we first start working on the next
star wars game we knew that we wanted to
reinvent or reimagine something about
Star Wars so we really focused on the
force and we came up with this idea of
the force over-the-top out of control
truly unleashed and then that kind of
led into some gameplay explorations and
making a game that was really all about
just kicking ass with the force every
time you hit a button you do something
visceral and powerful and it makes you
feel like a over the top super here the
force unleashed takes place between the
two trilogies so it picks up actually
we're episode 3 Revenge of the Sith
actually ends so it's a very dark time
in the galaxy Darth Vader's hunting down
the last of the Jedi and he finds while
he's hunting down one of these Jedi this
boy who he takes as his apprentice and
over the years he trains and teaches to
embrace the dark side so that this boy
who later becomes known as Starkiller
can go on and hunt down the last of Jedi
for Vader in the force on these we
really tried to make sure that it felt
like an epic Star Wars story and also
like the Star Wars films takes you to a
lot of different locations very diverse
location so we have a number of familiar
but also new locations you start the
game actually has Darth Vader on the
wiki homeworld of Kashi quigg towering
trees and as you slam stormtroopers or
wiki's into them they'll actually
splinter and break and collapse so it's
a very interactive but beautiful
environment as a game designer it's
actually very liberating and exciting to
be able to die in a game in an
established universe like the Star Wars
universe I think Star Wars is unique in
the sense that it's so deep and rich and
cohesive so that that is kind of a
benefit there but it also gives us a
really good set of parameters from the
outset so there are certain things we
know we'll never do within the context
of Star Wars certain types of content
that we would never do but at the same
time there's so much there to already
work with so it gives us a really great
launching pad and and one of the other
things that was very unique about the
force unleased is kind of the level that
George Lucas was involved early on in
the brainstorming and the story
development so we came up with a number
of different concepts and then took
those to George Lucas to talk them
through and and through that process we
came upon the idea of setting the game
between the two trilogies and he gave us
really kind of a history lesson of
what was going on in that or what is
going on in that time period you know he
told us this is what Darth Vader might
be up to do what the Emperor's up to
these are the types of characters that
you can use here's who maybe he's
off-limits here's who I really think you
should use he really encouraged us to
using the Emperor for example he
encouraged us to create brand new
characters which was great at lucasarts
were big believers that sound is at
least fifty percent of the experience
and a video game we're really fortunate
that we have access to a massive
Skywalker Sound library of Star Wars
sound effects but we also create a ton
of sounds in house and then we work with
the Foley artist up at Skywalker Sound
to create new sounds as well so we did
full Foley sessions for all of our
cinematics and for many of our big
in-game moments as well another
technology that we invest in heavily is
called euphoria which is true
biomechanical AI it infuses all the
characters you interact with in the
environment with true AI that allows
them to react to different things that
you might do that to them so if we pick
up a storm trooper he'll flail around if
you throw them he'll try and protect his
head if you pick up a crate and throw it
out and you might try and duck out of
the way if you grab him he might grab
onto an object nearby or another
character it really just increases the
sense that these are authentic
characters and it leads to a very
unpredictable gameplay experience when
we were designing the game we try to
make sure that every time you press a
button you are doing something that felt
Unleashed but as you go through the game
we also have these big beats that you
know get bigger in some cases moments
like taking out an eight EST and being
able to lift it up and actually crush
and slam it in the ground or take out a
big rank or monster you actually throw
your lightsaber into his eye and then
shock him silly and then we also have a
huge moma in the game which we've talked
about a lot but we haven't really shown
because we want to keep it as a surprise
when players actually play there's a
moment in the game where you actually
get a pull at Star Destroyer out of the
sky and crash it onto a planet the force
unleashed comes out on sep tember 16th
and we're actually really excited here
at Lucas arts because we are done with
the game now and it's a gold master and
in the box and ready to be shipped and
on shelf and I just can't wait for
people to get get their hands on it and
start to find out what fans think of the
story and what everybody thinks of the
gameplay and in the meantime I'm going
to Cancun to relax
you